russia launched this illegal and brutal
assault the world has come together in
solidarity with the indomitable people
of ukraine
last week 141 countries nearly
three-quarters of the entire membership
of the united nations voted to condemn
putin's war
and 39 countries including the uk canada
and the netherlands
voted to refer putin's actions to the
international criminal court
this is the largest such action the
court has ever seen and will allow the
chief prosecutor to
open an investigation to ensure putin
cannot commit these crimes with impunity
as ukrainians resist russia's onslaught
with courage and tenacity the
international community must aid their
struggle in every way that we can
we will only succeed if the whole
international community
moves together
with the same spirit of unity that we've
seen in recent days
justin and mark and i have been
discussing that today and later this
afternoon i'm going to be speaking to
the leaders of the united states france
and germany
further to coordinate our actions
to aid these efforts today the uk is
joining our dutch and canadian friends
to mobilize more practical and sustained
support for ukraine
our new international ukraine support
group will coordinate the efforts of the
international community to provide
long-term and unwavering assistance
now and in the future and we will be
encouraging more countries to join us
this is the moment for ukraine's friends
to create a coalition of humanitarian
economic and defensive military support
to ensure
that putin fails and that's why today
i'm announcing a further
175 million pounds of uk aid for ukraine
100 million dollars of which will be
provided directly to the ukrainian
government
this brings the total uk support
announced during this crisis to around
400 million pounds
after 12 days it's already clear that
putin has made a miscalculation he has
underestimated the ukrainians their
heroic resistance he's underestimated
their leader
and he has underestimated the unity of
the west and we will continue as
colleagues to do everything we can to
strengthen that unity in the days ahead
to ensure that putin fails in this
catastrophic invasion of ukraine thank
you very much
thank you prime minister johnson for
hosting it's great to be joined here by
uh prime minister jude as well it's been
a very productive first day of my trip
to europe we've been focused on
solidarity with partners and allies
we're focused on stronger economic ties
jobs growth and the middle cla and
support for the
middle class
[Music]
but also obviously for standing up for
democracy against authoritarianism and
standing with ukraine every step of the
way
this morning i was able to have an
audience with her majesty queen
elizabeth ii at windsor castle uh we
congratulated her obviously on the
platinum jubilee
and
was able to talk a little bit about the
situations we're facing and draw on her
long experience uh for having seen much
over these past past decades
when i met earlier with boris we
discussed stronger security ties
continuing to defend our shared values
continuing to our work together on
advancing free trade and creating more
middle class jobs
and also on climate action where we need
to build a sustainable secure future i
also had a bilateral meeting with mark
rutay where we talked about the enhanced
importance of nato uh continuing to work
together to fight disinformation and
protecting freedom of the press and
continuing to work uh strongly with our
friends in the european union
but of course throughout
the focus is on the people of ukraine
and our solidarity with ukraine are
pushing back against uh the illegal
russian invasion of ukraine and standing
up for democracies around the world
humanitarian
uk and the netherlands are close defense
partners working together to mobilize
the global community to step up to
support ukraine and we'll continue to
defend democracy and the values that
underpin it and continue to make sure
that putin is held accountable
today canada is announcing new sanctions
on 10 individuals complicit in this
unjustified invasion this includes
former and current senior government
officials oligarchs and supporters of
russian leadership the names of these
individuals come from a list compiled by
jailed opposition leader alexei navalny
these sanctions put increased pressure
on russia's leadership including on
putin's inner circle
this is of course in addition to all the
other sanctions we've announced
including our recent announcement on
imposing massive tariffs on russian and
belarusian imports
the work we're doing together is
punishing putin and his enablers where
it hurts most in particular by crippling
their financial systems and sanctioning
their central bank
so far in aid for ukraine canada has
sent about a billion dollars worth of
financial assistance and humanitarian
aid
but we have more to do
for today we continue to stand with
ukraine united and strong
thank you we are here today as close uh
transatlantic nato allies um
throughout history
our countries have always been closely
linked
and in times of crisis in times of war
we stand shoulder to shoulder
and so today as war and violence once
again cast a dark shadow over europe we
are working together
for peace and security on the european
continent
and i'd like to thank prime minister
johnson
borth i thank you so much for bringing
us together
today at this timely moment
because it has been another weekend of
horrific violence in ukraine
we knew it already but in recent days it
has been confirmed that putin remains
unmoved
we are dealing with an aggressor who
keeps crossing new boundaries
civilians and civilian targets and even
a nuclear power plant have been attacked
recently
and we know now that putin has used
cluster bombs
we can only guess what he plans to do
next
but one thing is certain russia's
aggression must stop
and in our meeting this morning we again
stressed the importance of unity
to all ukrainians we say this
your courage and your resistance
exemplified by president vladimir
zelinsky deserves our utmost respect
your result is our resolve we will
continue to stand by you in the past few
days aid and military supplies have been
sent to ukraine from the netherlands as
well as the uk and canada
and we will continue to do everything we
can to help canada
the netherlands is prepared to consider
and we are all prepared to consider all
possible sanctions that can help put
pressure on russia
and obviously there's a lot of debate
going on about
energy sanctions and here we move we
should not make a mistake
we have to ensure that they don't
generate unmanageable risks to energy
supplies in europe european countries
and beyond including ukraine
as has also been stated today by german
chancellor olaf schultz and i think
rightly so
so that means that we still need
european companies to continue their
work towards russia
and that is important and of course what
we need to do over time is to make sure
that we reduce dramatically our energy
dependency
on russia that's clear
finally i'm pleased that there is a
broad international agreement on the
fact that possible war crimes must be
investigated
we must document everything
that points towards human rights
violations now
so that when the time comes we can
prosecute
and try those responsible
peace and justice must have been out
over violence and injustice
thank you very much mark and thank you
justin let's go now to the media gary
gibbon channel 4.
thank you prime minister um can you
elaborate all perhaps a bit more about
the energy discussions and
where there's where they're going the
u.s secretary of state said there are
active discussions
for an oil ban from europe it sounds as
though you don't feel that's the case uh
prime minister and and you prime
minister
your views are characterized in the
newspapers this morning as saying the
west should have a climate change pass
should we bust through the caps for a
while in order to insulate europe from
russia whether it's going to turn
supplies off or we're going to
walk away from them in europe and one
quick one if i make you specifically
prime minister on refugees
um
whether the numbers are still 50 that
have come to this country or have gone
up a little uh it seems like they've
only gone up a little
isn't that embarrassing
thanks well let me let me just uh
before i bring in colleagues on the uh
on the hydrocarbons uh issue uh i think
there are there are different
dependencies in in different countries
and we have to uh we have to be mindful
of of that and
uh you can't simply close down uh use of
oil and gas uh overnight uh even from
from russia that's that's that's
obviously not something that uh every
country around the world can do uh we
can go fast in the in the uk other
countries can go fast but uh there are
there are different dependencies what we
need to do is to make sure that we're
all moving in the same direction and we
all share the same assumptions and that
we accelerate
that move and i think that is what uh
you're going to see and you've heard
that from
from leaders around the world and
actually i see no inconsistency by the
way uh in moving away uh from dependency
on uh on russian hydrocarbons to moving
away from dependency on our hydrocarbons
all together and uh you know you can see
how uh
this will encourage the world uh to go
gary for uh for for green solutions
wherever possible but clearly there is
going to be a transitional period we're
gonna have to look for supply we're
gonna have to look for substitute uh
supplies uh from elsewhere and we're
gonna have to do it uh together across
the uh the entire coalition of countries
uh that is now uh condemning uh putin's
actions and on your on your um your
point about um
uh
the the uk's uh
reception of of of refugees we are
absolutely determined to uh be as
generous as we possibly can and as i
speak to you all we're processing
thousands clearly of applications
clearly as the as the situation has has
got worse
uh we are going to have to make sure
that we we do even more and the routes
that we have already the family reunion
route offers the prospect of hundreds of
thousands uh coming here uh the the
humanitarian sponsorship group is is
also
uncapped and uh we're putting people out
into uh into all the surrounding
countries into into poland into bulgaria
romania as well as into uh into cali to
france uh to make sure that we receive
people who and we help we help people to
come don't forget the uk uh since 2015
uh has been the most generous of within
a great respect to mark and all other
european colleagues we've been the most
most generous of uh of all european
countries in settling uh vulnerable
people uh we took a large number of
afghan refugees as you remember under op
uh pitting and uh we will uh and
a hundred and four thousand uh hong kong
chinese who have applied under asking we
will be very very generous as the people
of this country uh would expect and will
want to people fleeing the war in in
ukraine and i know that's going to be
the instinct of the british people but
uh colleagues on the on the on the uh
hydrocarbons the the painful reality is
that we are still very much dependent on
russian gas and russian oil
and if we now would force european
companies to quit doing business with
russia that would have
enormous ramifications
around europe including ukraine but also
around the world so we have to
dramatically reduce our dependency
on gas and oil from russia that will
take time
a statement earlier today by olive
schultz the chancellor of germany i
think was in the same direction so the
painful reality is there
and that means that
we have to be very clear and make no
mistakes here this is a step-by-step
approach
and that means that we have to make sure
that the energy supply is in this part
of the world again including ukraine but
also in the rest of the world are not
hindered and that will take time
i think what is clear is that
many countries have realized that
continued reliance on
russia's oil and gas is a problem for
the future what we're seeing with
the solidarity and the unity
not just of
countries and democracies across europe
and north america but indeed countries
around the world
looking at
trying to secure
more
reliable sources of energy particularly
green sources
what we're seeing is a shift in europe
and elsewhere to understand that russia
is no longer a reliable partner what
vladimir putin has broken here
is a trust where i've heard a number of
europeans reflect on it's too bad that
we are so dependent on russian oil but
we're not going to make that mistake
again and they are moving away from it
canada imports negligible amounts of
russian petrochemicals and oil we've
banned that but we are of course
self-sustainable in terms of uh
oil and energy but we will be there to
support as the world moves beyond
russian oil and indeed beyond fossil
fuels to have more renewables in our mix
thanks very much gary a raymond fillion
of tva
sure
what will canada do with regards to its
military spending
right now
if you can answer in both official
languages
as you know
a number of years ago we put forward a
defense plan that included increasing
our defense spending by 70 percent
but we also recognize that the context
is changing rapidly around the world and
we need to make sure that the women and
men who serve in the canadian armed
forces have all the equipment necessary
to be able to stand strongly as we
always have as members of nato we will
continue to look at what more we can do
thanks very much um justin uh fleur
landsback from nos
um i have a question for prime minister
johnson
uh last week there was a journalist in
poland that's asked you
why do ukrainians have to flee their
homes why are their children taking the
hits in this war while putin's friends
and his inner circle are still living in
london's most beautiful houses
and taking their children to private
schools
i was just wondering has anything
changed since that question was asked
thank you very much fleur yes it
certainly has and i think that you if
you look at
what we've done
just today uh with the the economic
crime bill we're taking uh we're taking
steps uh to ensure that we whip aside
the veil of of anonymity uh that that
obscures the ownership of the of the
properties that uh that you describe so
you can no longer use a a bogus company
uh to conceal your ownership of a of a
property where
we are uh making sure that we have new
powers to uh
distrain to take people's uh to take
people's assets uh and we think that
that will have uh
we think that the whole package of
measures that we're putting forward
today uh will uh have rod ascend uh in
just in just a few days time so we're
moving very very fast on that but fleur
i hope that uh you know our viewers and
all of you will recognize that that is
in addition uh to the huge work that the
uk has done together uh with uh with
mark and with justin on the big package
of international sanctions and um
if you look at what we did on uh
together on on swift what we did on the
on the uh the russian central bank uh it
uh it's already had a profound effect
and i think i'm right in saying that
even today the the russian stock market
is is not opening and uh you know
there's not a testimonial i necessarily
seek uh but i you know i observe that
the uh the russian foreign ministry uh
said that the uk had not been entirely
uh helpful uh in this uh in this regard
towards uh their own uh economic
interests and i'm sure you'll have seen
uh what she said and we are going to
continue uh to work with
colleagues to ensure that
we tighten the the vice
around president putin's regime
look what's happening now is that uh he
the the president of russia is plainly
doubling down
he's decided that
he's going to continue with an all-out
onslaught on
centers of habitation in a way that we
think is utterly repugnant it's clear
that we're going to have to do more and
as as friends and partners that's what
that's what we're going to do
uh i didn't think that question was for
anybody else let's go to jason graves
from the the daily mail
um thank you you've all had some success
with your sanctions they're squeezing
russia but also having an impact here
we've seen the gas price treble we're
seeing petrol passes heading towards two
panzer liter what would you say prime
minister to people who desperately want
to help but are worried about that can
you give a commitment now that there is
going to be more health on the way
mr trudeau can ask his canada ready to
uh increase its oil and gas output to
help between mr rutter and others
uh off that russian gas and also you've
seen the queen today how is she we've
not seen it for a while is she fighting
fit
jason look it's a really important
question i think everybody is going to
be uh thinking that you you've ever
already seen what's happened to the
price of oil uh this this this matters
uh which is why i think what mark had to
say earlier on about the need to
proceed in in steps is is correct uh and
we must
you know do everything we can to protect
uh consumers and the public there are
going to be impacts let's be in no doubt
there are going to be impacts uh but i
think that uh it's the right it's the
right thing to do uh but we've got a and
it's it's the right thing it's
completely the right thing to do to uh
to move away from
russian hydrocarbons for dependence on
russian hydrocarbons but we've got to do
it step by step so far the success of
of the west has been in the unity uh
that we've shown i think we're all
increasingly united in the view that
we've got to move away now
from russian hydrocarbons we've got to
do it together we've got to make sure
that we have substitute uh and
substitute supply and that's what we're
uh we're working on as well
we will do everything that we can to
ensure that we have uh substitute and
substitute supply so uh one of the
things that we're looking at is the uh
possibility the uh of uh using more of
our own hydrocarbons and you'll have
heard already what uh the business
secretary has had to say about about
licenses
for
for uk
[Music]
uk's own domestic production
that doesn't mean that we are in any way
abandoning our commitment to reducing
co2 you can you can do that but we've
got to reflect the uh the reality uh
that
there is a crunch on at the moment uh we
need to intensify uh our self-reliance
as a transition uh with more
hydrocarbons but what we also need to do
is go for more nuclear and uh and much
more uh use of renewable energy and i'm
going to be setting out a an energy
strategy and energy supply strategy for
the country in the in the days ahead so
that people have a sense of how we're
going to meet people's needs over the
the the short medium and and long term
marieke
sorry justin sorry it's all good um what
we learned over the past couple of years
is that global
challenges uh have impacts domestically
uh
covet crisis was a perfect example of
disrupted supply chains that
led to significant inflation challenges
around the world
we made a promise to canadians that we'd
have people's backs and that's exactly
what we've been focused on
the challenge
right now of russia's illegal invasion
of ukraine is having ripple effects
around the world not just uh in energy
prices for canadians and for people in
europe but for people in the global
south as well disruption of the un food
program disruptions that are happening
that we are going to have to adjust to
we're going to have to make sure we are
there for each other
and that is the focus that we have
as partners but it's why we've all been
reaching out around the world to talk
with fellow leaders about the challenges
they're facing the challenges their
people are facing because what we are
learning
about russia's unreliability as a
trading partner needs to be remembered
but we also have to work together to
provide substitutes to provide
alternatives and of course we need to
move
forward to decarbonizing our economies
but we need to do that in a way that
supports people through that process and
we're going to continue doing that
in regards to her majesty i have
i have the particular privilege of
having known her majesty uh or for about
45 years now uh and i can tell you that
in my conversation
with her this morning she was as
insightful and perspicacious as ever
very interested in what's going on asked
me all sorts of questions about canada
and we had a really useful for me anyway
conversation about global events as we
always do
thanks very much justin okay
uh uh marika walsh from the from the
globe and mail
good afternoon thank you um a few
questions for all three of you
uh you're talking about this
humanitarian coalition what exactly is
that what good will it do for the people
of ukraine concretely
and regarding sanctions uh prime
minister trudeau is announcing more
today but we haven't seen it actually
change the behavior of russia in ukraine
so
is enough being done on that and prime
minister johnson particularly for you
you spend more than the two percent
target in nato canada spends well less
is that acceptable to you
um
so uh
should we have a go at that first how's
it going okay well thank you
uh marika thank you very much look uh
yes it's true we spend about 2.4 percent
now um uh but uh look i i
um i i think that
canada is a fantastic ally friend and
partner and i'm not gonna make any
comment on uh on uh on canada's approach
except to say uh this that i do think
that
the world is clearly changing and i
think that what we can't do uh post uh
the invasion of ukraine is assume that
we can go back to a kind of status quo
anti a kind of new normalization in the
way that we did after the invasion of
crimea in 2014 or the the the seizure of
crimea and and and uh
and the donbass area uh we've got to
recognize that things have changed and
that we need a new focus on our
collective security and i think that
that that is that is kind of uh
increasingly understood uh by by
everybody and on your on your first
point about what the humanitarian
coalition uh look i mean the whole world
is now coming together to try to help
avert a total catastrophe in uh in in
ukraine it's it's already very very grim
uh indeed we're doing everything in our
power uh to prevent it from getting uh
from getting worse um
and one of the most important things is
to look after people fleeing uh the war
zone and all of us in our in our
different ways are doing a lot as and
you'll have heard the uh the sums that
we've announced today to uh to help the
immediate vicinity and and what we're
doing to take people i know that both uh
the gentleman here who are here with me
uh their countries have a fantastic
record of humanitarian uh help
well
on defense spending we decided early
january when the new team the new
cabinet started to ramp up uh defense
spending
by billions of euros
and that will bring us close to the uh
two percent uh and probably we need to
do more
particularly given what has happened
over the last two weeks but the
netherlands will spend a lot of extra
money on defense and i think rightly so
the european coalition i think it is
crucial
that this is not only nato european
union working together but that is the
whole world
coming together to
defend the basic values
and the international legal order as it
has been established after the second
world war and which is now being
challenged by one country invading the
second biggest european nation being
ukraine being invaded by the biggest
european nation so this is this is a
huge event and this has huge uh impact
on the whole world and we have to bring
together africa latin america asia
everyone who wants to be part of
humanity
to be part of such a humanitarian
coalition and
yes i agree with you the sanctions so
far have not had the desired effect they
have a huge effect on russia they are
not against the russians
but against the russian leadership but
of course it will have an effect
uh unavoidably and ultimately also on
individual russians that that we cannot
prevent
and i think in the longer term it will
have a big impact on their chat will
also have an impact on
how they will move forward but you are
absolutely right at the moment in the
short term
uh it has not led to the result that
they stopped the invasion that's true
but that's why we are resolved in being
there for the long term the courage of
ukrainians and standing up
to the russian invaders has inspired and
humbled
us all
and we need to show ourselves as
determined to push back against putin
against the kremlin
as hard as we can and as effectively as
we can
and that's where i mean from the
beginning uh boris and i and a couple of
others were pushing so hard on swift
on uh the central banks on on the
russian central bank including going
after their ability to draw on their
reserves something that even a week ago
we didn't think
would be in the cards and yet seeing
just how strongly
democracies around the world have stood
and responded i think is a surprise to
putin perhaps a little bit of a surprise
to all of us as well that we actually
can stand
and push back really hard
for the principles that drive us and
quite frankly the
unprecedented
display of support of 141 countries at
the united nations
supporting this resolution
means that as we move forward this is of
course about ukrainians and ukraine but
it's also about more than that
it's about standing up
for the rules-based order
that has led to unprecedented peace and
stability and growth around the world
over the past many decades
and the pushback that
one like russia like putin specifically
cannot overthrow
those 75 plus years of peace and
stability
and still benefit
from the economic largesse and growth
that comes with that and that
firmness is not just western democracies
like us
that is
something that we've heard in our
conversations all three of us with
partners around the world
who don't have the same kinds of ties to
ukraine but are very very concerned
about the violation of the rule of law
the principle that suddenly might might
be right once again
the principle of territorial integrity
respect for sovereignty the kind of
neo-colonialism that vladimir putin is
trying to impose upon ukrainians
that's not going to fly and the strength
and the resolve
of countries around the world to say no
this is a moment to stand
for democracy
against disinformation misinformation
propaganda
and to stay true to these values that
have led to respect and prosperity
around the world that we continue to
need to fight for including
in many different parts of the world
whether it's afghanistan uh or elsewhere
as well
thank you thank you thank you so much
okay excuse me
foreign
prosperity
thank you very much uh justin uh last
question is to yoast dauber of financial
duckblood
thank you um
you have all stressed the importance of
unity in the western response to to
russia
but when it comes to energy sanctions
there seems to be
a big difference between your position
and the position of the united states
with
secretary of state blinking coming out
in favor of an oil plan
and also saying that there are
advanced discussions with the europeans
about this
and was
the american secretary of state wrong to
say that there are
advanced discussions and um prime
minister voter can you please also
elaborate what the discussions uh you
are having in the european union context
are about this thank you
thanks uh so let me just just say
quickly that uh no i don't think tony
blinken was wrong in the sense that
we're all together now moving very very
fast and seeing the the uh something
that perhaps uh three or four weeks ago
we would never have con considered is
now very much on the table uh we have to
consider how uh we can all move away uh
as fast as possible from dependence
reliance on russian hydrocarbons uh
russian oil and gas and everybody's
doing that everybody's on the same
journey uh some countries will find it
faster and easier than others that's all
but we're going to do it i'm going to do
it together because and we're going to
work together on making sure that we all
have uh the substitutes and the supplies
that we that we need
i agree and if um
so in that sense it is a
step-by-step
process and we have to make sure to
deleverage our dependency
on russian gas and russian oil and
whilst acknowledging at the moment that
that dependency is to a certain extent
still there
and
if we would force companies to quit
doing business with russia in that realm
that would have enormous consequences
because it would
basically undermine supply chains the
world over particularly in europe it
would also have an impact on ukraine
itself
and therefore my plea is
to do this diligently
and not overnight
and making sure that we speed up
the programs all our countries to
decarbonize uh to green our economies it
makes it more important to do that
okay everybody thank you very much thank
you colleagues uh very much indeed thank
you for your time thank you thank you
the prime minister they're wrapping up
that joint news conference uh with the
canadian and dutch prime ministers uh
boris johnson announcing 175 million
pounds in new aid for ukraine he was
also asked about refugees and he said
we're going to have to make sure we do
even more and he also announced he's
going to set out an energy supply
strategy for the country in the days
ahead um just as that came to a close uh
events have been getting underway in the
house of commons let's take you there
live the home secretary delivering a
statement on ukraine
because she does actually give me the
chance to clarify what is happening when
it comes to the actual fast moving
picture um my writing friend the
secretary of state for deluxe has
already said that i was in poland on
friday but this is a rapidly moving
picture and i think mr speaker it's
important for all colleagues in the
house to know that the first quality
assured figures on the ukrainian family
scheme will come this evening and
they're going to be published this
evening the figures that are public are
absolutely inaccurate and they have not
been assured by the